thank you
[Music]
hello everyone thank you for joining me
I'll wait a couple of seconds for people
to sit down but can you hear me right at
the back all good okay cool
I'll let people sit down get comfortable
there's some seats up here there's some
two there
cool
well thanks so much everyone for joining
me giving me your time today really
appreciate it
um my goal with this time that you've
given me is just to try and give you as
much value as possible particularly
around the context of what do top
performing recruiters have in common
and also how can we get better at hiring
them
so just just to help me out here I'm
going to ask you to just engage with me
because I think it's way more fun when
you guys get involved rather than me to
speak at all of you but just so I can
get some context could you put your hand
up if you listen to the podcast that I
host or have at some point or checked it
out okay
firstly thank you so much really
appreciate it so yeah one of the things
that just a bit of context about myself
and why I'm quite well positioned I
believe to talk about what top
performing recruiters have in common
um is five years ago when I was in
recruitment I started a podcast a
recruitment podcast there's a lot more
podcasts now
um but yeah I started a podcast when I
was in recruitment with this simple idea
that if I interview great recruiters and
find out sort of how they got to the top
what they do differently the challenges
they learned from then hopefully that
can help one other person in Industry be
more successful so I've been doing that
for five years religiously every single
week and we've interviewed over 400
recruitment professionals now who are
current top performers they're
entrepreneurs so every single week I'm
sitting down getting to know these
people finding out what they would do
differently the challenge they face
along the way and all of that and then
the final bit of context is two years
ago I started a business called
treatment mentors and really simply it's
an all-in-one training development
platform where we partner with ambitious
recruitment companies who are committed
to unlocking the full potential of their
teams and our mission really simply as
you can see there is to help thousands
of recruiters achieve their potential by
providing the best on-demand training
development delivered by today's top
performers we've just found that
recruiters are a lot more engaged and
consistent when it comes to spending
time at getting better at the job when
they know they're learning from people
that have been there and done it rather
than people that did the job 5 10 15
years ago which is very typical of the
training experiences that I experience
when I was in Recruitment and other
people do
so
who put your hand up if you can relate
to this when someone asks you how did
you get into recruitment who answers
with this put your hand up
yeah
um a lot of us right so I think for me I
think that's one of the amazing things
about our industry is that so many
people from different walks of lives
different experiences can end through
our industry and be successful
but the challenge of that is how the
hell do we know one absolute exceptional
top billing recruiter looks like when
they walk through the door because they
all come in different shapes different
sizes and different backgrounds so these
are some of the things that I'm going to
share that I've found when sitting down
with people
so the goal here is by the end of this
session I want all of you to be able to
yeah identify the most common traits and
characteristics of top performers and
also most importantly develop strategies
to discover these traits in potential
hires feel free to take notes but at the
end you're going to be able to scan the
QR code and we put together just a nice
key takeaway document you can take away
to Super bite size easy to digest
so how have we uncovered the common
characteristics and traits well
how I kick off my podcast or how I have
kicked it off over the last 200 episodes
is I've asked people the million pound
question
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think make up a highly
successful recruitment consultant in
today's market that's the key bit in
today's market so what we did is I
didn't but I got someone to listen to
like the first 10 minutes of the last
200 episodes put a bit of a spreadsheet
together and we wrote down the responses
and I'm going to share the top three
that have come out of that and then a
few that came around the sort of top
five top six characteristics and traits
so this is the first one
probably not surprised by this one at
all resilience whenever we speak about
recruitment you'll probably hear this
word resilience come up I'm going to
sort of talk to you a bit about sort of
my perspective on resilience but when
looking online for a definition that
sort of resonated with me we can see
here the definition by American
Psychological Association resilience is
the process and outcome of successfully
adapting to difficult or challenging
life experiences especially through
mental emotional and behavioral
flexibility and adjustment to external
and internal demand so
I'm not surprised that when it comes to
working in recruitment we need to be
resilient there's a lot of things that
we have to deal with that comes our way
a lot of things we can't control and
that's people right and it's bloody
difficult
however for me when I'm sitting down
with people that have been successful
over the long term built a successful
recruitment career over five plus years
my thoughts are resilience is absolutely
crucial probably even more like really
crucial at the beginning of your
recruitment career
and you have to find yourself brushing
things off bouncing back and going again
and at the beginning you really have to
build that muscle
however for me when I sit down with
people that have been successful over
the long term
they they're not coming in every day
bouncing back because that is exhausting
that is exhausting to pick yourself up
every single day and bounce back with
this resilience muscle it's absolutely
still there but for me what the best
recruiters are great at is what I put
here detaching from the outcome
and you might hear things in your office
like look my best piece of advice to you
is don't get too high to the highs don't
get two loads of the lows do everything
you can to stay in that middle
so for me yes resilience that's
something that we're probably going to
find in most recruiters but I think the
best recruiters over a long sustained
period have got really good at
experiencing a setback and coming on or
going into the straight call that not
affecting them and that's because what
they've got really good at is detaching
from the outcome making doing the thing
the thing not what you get out of doing
the thing that's what the best
recruiters are focus on every single day
and I think if you were to bounce back
every single day it's difficult
so for me what's helped me in my life I
don't know if any of you are familiar
with stoicism or Ryan holiday's work but
for me this has really helped me in my
life in terms of trying to adapt
principles that just help me have more
good days than bad days and I absolutely
love this quote I think it's something
to have top of mind
um in Recruitment and I think the best
recruiters will view their journey and
recruitment like this so yeah focus on
the things you can control recruiters
are really good at that let go of
everything else and turn every new
obstacle into an opportunity to get
better stronger
and tougher
so I'm sure we're not surprised by
resilience but I just wanted to give you
my take on what that sort of means to me
was sitting down with these people uh if
you're someone that likes to read books
or audio books I'd highly recommend the
obstacle is the way absolutely great
book to read
the second most common trait is
relationship Builder
so again I wasn't surprised to see this
because from all of my conversations the
best recruiters are not transactional
ones
I think we've all at some at some point
heard a story in the office where we
have a recruiter go this person I placed
in their first job and now they're
hiring for their team and now they've
asked me to help them build their team
you don't get into that position if you
don't double down on building
relationships so I think for me
something to definitely take away
um uh from this is how many people in
our office really focus on not just the
short-term wins
um but also the long-term opportunity
are they doing the right thing
consistently and I think in order to
have that long-term success in
recruitment
you can't be transactional you can be
but it's probably going to be a bit more
difficult there's going to be a lot more
Ebbs and flows but I think being a solid
relationship Builder connecting with
people playing the long game is
absolutely essential
third and final trait that came out we
put mindset here but what sort of came
up in in different ways was basically
growth mindset positive mindset again
things that you're probably not
surprised by
but I think again the best recruiters
do have a growth mindset
and really simply all that means is
they go through an obstacle or they face
an obstacle or they experience a setback
and the first question is isn't oh my
God is the client's fault it's a
candidate's fault and they're pointing
the finger they take responsibility and
they go what could I've done differently
what could I've learned from this
opportunity and they and they sort of
view their setbacks as learning
opportunities now that isn't to say that
they don't have their moments of effing
and blinding how has a client done this
the candidates dropped out we've all
been there you have to find your own
mechanisms that work for me it was going
for a walk it was getting out the office
so I don't give that negative energy to
everyone else I'm sure we've all been
around those people that love to give
everyone else a negative energy when
goes wrong but I think mindset
specifically having a growth mindset
viewing challenges as learning
opportunities and these people are
willing to take responsibility they
don't have a victim mindset and I don't
try and pointing the finger they tell
responsibility and they're trying to
learn
top three trades that's what came out of
all the different conversations that we
had and people answering that question
so just to recap the top three traits
that came out when we did this exercise
was resilience relationship Builder
and mindset
now there's probably a number of other
traits that you think are really
consistent in top performers these were
sort of common ones that came out of
just the sort of top three
um
couple there that I really like for me I
definitely think the best recruiters are
curious
can annoy people but I always wanted to
ask questions I think that's a good sign
um
I think accountability I was just
talking about it there that's like so
important like I think your time in
recruitment will be really miserable if
you're really good at pointing the
finger
um and I think you've got way more
chance to grow develop improve if you're
willing to take accountability
so these are just again a few of the
other traits that came out
a lot of the time when we ask this
question to a lot of people
so just really quickly again just asking
you to engage with me here how many of
you would you say who manage or hiring
your team how many of you would you say
have complete Clarity on the traits you
look for when hiring for someone in your
team that maybe doesn't have much
experience or just hiring for someone in
your business do you have complete
Clarity on the characteristics that
these people have to have in order for
you to consider hiring them
put your hand up if you feel like you've
got Clarity on that
it's not many right and I think this is
the thing it's like so many people can
there's so many we hear so many stories
of like yeah so we've got um Geraldine
who's our top biller and she used to
work in Greg's
right so how does that how does that
work then like how did you go from there
to come recruit to just have all these
people in different backgrounds and
different walks of life so in terms of
being really strict or sort of focused
on what are the non-negotiable traits
that I need to look for uh when it comes
to hiring people it can be difficult
so this is what I would encourage you
over the sort of next part of this talk
is how can we get to the position where
a lot more of you part of your hand and
you have a lot more clarity on your
non-negotiables
so I'm going to take this from my
conversation with Alex Elliot who is a
successful recruitment entrepreneur
built a business called liquid personnel
which he exited
um and we had a really great podcast
episode I'd highly encourage you to
check that out and this was the exercise
that he gave when successfully scaling
his recruitment business because as we
all know one of the biggest reasons you
won't hit your business goals your
objectives this year is because you
haven't got the right people in the
right seats
it's the problem that we try and solve
for our customers so for those of you
that didn't put your hand up a really
practical exercise for you to walk away
and do in your business
is the following and this is something
that Alex highly recommends particularly
when you're a business of a smaller size
this should be a lot more easier to do
so the Practical exercise here is sit
down with your top performing recruiters
and find out and understand what do they
have in common with each other what do
they possess that's consistent and write
these things down is it curiosity is it
work ethic is it having a growth mindset
but something that could be really
useful to walk away with from today is
how can I get better at hiring amazing
people for my business that work out in
a successful well a best place to start
is with the people inside your
organization and what made them
successful
um and the reason why sort of
Alex shares this which I think is just a
really good point here this isn't to say
that if you do find out what those
common characteristics are that you
can't hire anyone that doesn't possess
them while like shared here is like if
you at least have some non-negotiables a
bit of science behind who you hire and
why and what you look for it's just
stacking the odds in your favor of these
people actually being successful and not
being part of the higher attrition
numbers that we have in our industry
so again just a really practical
exercise here a bit of a top tip in
terms of yeah do this exercise and
hopefully that should mean that you're
going to put the odds in your favor to
yeah get better at hiring better people
and then to sort of build on this Okay
so we've got the common characteristics
we've got the traits
been on a conversation with Alex my next
question Tim was then okay well if I've
done that how can I really make sure
that I uncover these and what Alex
shared was where he's found a lot of
people slip up or not be on the board of
is they have the traits it might be uh
growth mindset curiosity
um and accountability but then they
don't map their interview process to
uncovering those traits that are now
non-negotiable to you your business your
team that you look for
so this is a really common stumbling
block so we just put a few other
examples here on like how can we go
about looking for these traits and if
you have not got your interview process
mapped to uncovering resilience
uncovering growth mindset it's going to
be a lot more difficult to hire these
people consistently and get it right so
again this may sound really simple how
many of you actually do it I don't know
but yeah let's have a look at our
interview process are we being
consistent are we looking for the same
things and let's make sure our interview
process maps to the traits that we're
actually looking for in our people
cool so again just to be sort of super
practical here
um not trying to teach stock eggs a lot
of your job is asking good quality
questions but let's say our uh we're
looking for the common traits uh that I
sort of shared with you the top three
a bit of an example question here that
we could use a resilience something you
might already ask give me an example in
your life when you have experience a
setback and how you overcame it
we can be really intentional with our
questions in our interview process to
uncover evidence that these people
demonstrate resilience or more of these
traits
racist what sort of question can we ask
there
what is the most important relationship
you have built in your life so far
again we can be really intentional with
our questions uh when trying to uncover
why we should hire these people and and
looking for particular traits that we
want on our people
and then a bit of an example here from a
mindset perspective tell me about time
when something didn't go
um the way you wanted and at work and
what you learned from it obviously what
we're trying to uncover there is I don't
think many hires will work out in
recruitment if you ask them a question
like that and they go yeah it was always
my colleagues fault it was my manager's
fault easy to pass to blame not sure how
successful they're going to be in
recruitment
now again just another sort of
actionable sort of interview tip here as
we come towards um the end here and
going to be more than welcome to answer
some questions uh if you want to do that
um but this came from Alex Elliott again
because obviously those questions I just
shared with you fairly simple
um fairly easy to implement
but I think what's going to give you
even more confidence is looking for as I
put here as much evidence of these
traits being demonstrated as you can not
just recent examples or in their last
job because we want as much evidence as
possible to back up that this person
throughout their life has demonstrated
these traits that we're looking for so I
think something that a lot of people
shared on the podcast is in their
interviews they like to peel back the
onion
um Charles tell me about a time that you
had a setback when you was younger and
you were overcome it just looking at
your child side to use your name
um like let's let's dig deeper let's
find out who these people are and can we
find more and more evidence in their
Journey up until this point where
they're sitting in front of you
potentially joining you on your journey
in your business to back up that they're
people that have resilience have a
growth mindset they're accountable and
these types of things
so yeah dive into their past and collect
as much evidence as possible
um during the interview process that
will hopefully give you even more
confidence now of course people still
may not work out
but I think it's going to give you a
better chance
so to recap them
we've gone through the importance of
identifying the most common traits and
characteristics of your top performers
which when we did this exercise for all
of the people that we've interviewed was
resilience relationship Builder mindset
I'd really encourage you if you could do
anything to yeah commit to finding out
what are your common traits what are the
common characteristics in your business
and your teams that you feel is an
enable enables people to be successful
in your environment
um so the importance of identifying
those
then we spoken about developing really
practical strategies to discover these
traits in potential hires because of
course if we found the recipe or we're
happy with what we believe makes a
successful recruiter then let's be
really intentional about uh trying to
uncover this in people that we hire so
as Alex put here interview Consultants
interview your hard performing
Consultants then most importantly once
you're happy with those map your
interview process the journey that you
take people on before you decide to hire
them with the right questions with the
intentional questions to hopefully
uncover did they have these traits
that's what I wanted to go through with
you today you can scan that you won't be
asked for your email I promise
you'll scan that and then you'll be able
to download this which will take up all
of your the key insights key takeaways
actual tips
that's everything I wanted to share with
you today really appreciate you giving
me the time wanted to make it hopefully
as valuable as possible in a really
short um focused way we've got some time
here for questions the lovely man at the
back has happened to run around the
microphone if anyone wants to ask a
question we've got yeah five or five
minutes here they're more than welcome
on anything that I've just sort of gone
through
got a question at the front thanks for
being the first it's all right no it's
okay
thank you for that
um what's your name sorry my name
is
I'm not familiar with
you with one thing that I look for when
I'm hiring which I think
um has helped me be successful is
looking
um at the candidates and
ascertaining their ability and
willingness to learn yeah
so all the resilience all the
relationship building they need to learn
that the willingness to learn yeah yeah
did that come up in yeah absolutely a
common sentence that you'll hear from a
top former you'll hear in your offices
um
the basically not being complacent
there's always things that I can learn
top performers say that I was surprised
that that wasn't one of your yeah I mean
it's the thing is like it's very easy
when you get asked that question to go
to like the common things I mean the
resilience and these things but
absolutely from all the conversations
the top performers that don't get
complacent and the only way they don't
get complacent is by always being
willing to learn yeah what can I learn
from the person it's just gone through
the door and yeah always be willing to
learn you can learn mindset you can
learn relationships so how do you try
and find that in people then
by ascertaining where they've learned
things how much they do self-learning
yeah nice perfect yeah great example
yeah then there's some good evidence
there right yeah cool anyone else have a
question
what's your name sorry my name is nice
to meet you nice to meet you
um great presentation thank you so you
mentioned resilience relationships and
mindset are the key sort of traits for a
top recruiter
um but you know in terms of the
transition of the recruiter him or
herself
where do you actually see the top
performance actually taking place is it
in their first early years would you say
it's more in their mid sort of cap years
two three years would you say five years
and above and also on top of that
question
do they also have a network of their own
mentors to to be at Peak Performance in
order to become a top biller or top
recruiter
so the first question there is when do
you believe what the top foot when does
that come in their career how long how
long were you working like which sort of
area do they how long does it take like
when do they actually become that type
of performer in their first few years
yeah in their mid-cap years or sort of
at a later stage what do you what have
you noticed with those people that
you've interviewed
let's be honest like we've all there's
always been those success stories of I
came in here I did my first deal it was
50 Grand so like for me recruitment is a
longer
um and I think the most successful
people have done it over a sustained
period of time of course you can go into
recruitment you can work in industry for
two years three years could you
potentially make six figures potentially
but it just depends what game you're
playing are you in it for the long run
and I think the most successful
recruiters I've sat down with that I
think
um yeah really showcase that are people
that have done it over a long sustained
period of time
so of course you can have people that
achieve success quickly but for me I
think when I speak to business owners
they'd love more people to stay in the
business for the long run and there's
less people in their business that have
done it for five plus years
so I think it depends on how you're
measuring success but of course there's
always those success stories and it's
why
um part of the reason why I started the
podcast like why a lot of people love to
sell recruitment that you can earn six
figures in your first year which we
organize absolute bollocks
um and we don't tell them how hard it is
right
um and then the other part on the on the
mentorship yeah I think again this comes
back to the person's question at the
front on these top performers are always
willing to learn and I think yeah they
they can be very intentional to get that
learning so it could be outside the
organization it could be internal but I
think the smart people will try and find
people that have been where they are and
they're now a couple of steps ahead and
ask those people advice I think yeah
some great recruiters will do that for
sure
cool what time uh what time one more
question Charles coming in Sam
here you go mate
um
so I've I've I work in l d now but I
still sometimes get involved in the
interview process yeah and the
resilience question for example give us
an example uh in your life where you've
experienced setback we've had we've
heard so many people come back and said
you know I tore my ACL and then I came
back and I was able to play sport again
relationship building and then they give
a great example of where they built
relationships and then the mindset I've
always been open to learning I read
books but then a couple of months into
the job they flop
all the evidence and they're not
resilient that's right and um you know I
think it's a mixture of you know some
Rector X you know prepping them really
well and doing your job PPT as well now
well now yeah but I'm just I'm curious
from your perspective from the people
that you've interviewed you know what
other things can we do in an interview
process
um to test people on these three things
if we're just getting great answers to
those initial questions yeah I mean it's
it's a great question I think the thing
that's sort of top of mind I think it's
back to Alex's Point Charles is like
sort of the the goal here isn't to make
every single person we hire a dead
certain I think it's let's stack the
cards in our favor and have more of a
silence behind what we look for and that
should hopefully mean that we have more
people that when they do uh get three
months in the job and they need
resilience they actually have it so I
think you're always going to have people
that don't quite live those truths but I
think if you do this then uh you should
obviously have more people uh that do it
than don't so I think something I guess
maybe worth sharing
um when I speak to a lot of recruitment
owners I do think it could be worth if
you're experiencing now other things you
could use is like tools psychometric
stuff like I think if you could
introduce any sort of science or data
points to back up okay from what they've
shared this should mean that there's
someone that can that possesses
resilience but I think for me it then
it's then also like just like Alex said
like trying to get as much evidence as
possible so like although you've asked
that question let's make sure that's not
the only story they gave you and how can
we find two three four more stories
which wasn't when their rhetoric told
them look you know that story you told
me about when I uh qualified you use
that one when Charles asked you that
question do you know what I mean so I
mean it's just digging deeper hope
that's helpful
um cool thanks so much everyone really
appreciate your time awesome
[Applause]
[Music]